their performances were all outstanding
year the nominees for Best Performance
by an actor in a leading role Don
Cheadle in Hotel Rwanda Johnny Depp in
Finding Neverland
they are Nardo DiCaprio in the Aviator
Clint Eastwood and Million Dollar Baby
Jamie Foxx in ray
and the Oscar goes to Jamie Foxx and
this is the first Academy Award and
second nomination for Jamie five
the 10th person to be nominated in both
acting categories in the same year
I guess we got to do it again Oh oh yeah
you're ready
that's the Ray Charles give it up for
Ray Charles and his beautiful legacy and
thank you Ray Charles for living I got
so many people to thank tonight and
first time I started out with Taylor
Hackford Taylor you took a chance man I
mean that love for Ray Charles was deep
down in the earth stone when you open it
up and it's cracked open and the
spilling and everybody is drowning in
this love and I thank you for taking a
chance on this film and thank you for
waiting 15 years to get me to do it uh I
want to thank you want to thank crusader
I want to thank I want to thank my
agents I want to thank Rick Kurtzman I
want to thank Kim Hodge I don't thank us
Steve schmuck I want to thank my
managers Jamie King and Marcus King
let's uh let's live this African
American dream that's beautiful I'm glad
I'm with you and I ain't never leaving
you so I love you uh I got a chance to
meet a whole lot of people experiencing
this and other people don't want to
think I want to thank my sister for foot
11 of nothing but pure love I want to
thank my daughter for telling me just
before I got up here if you don't win
dad you're still good
I'm just see Oprah and I see hailey I
just want to say your names I want to
talk to you later both of you because
Oprah gotta allowed me to meet somebody
by the name of Sidney Poitier and uh yes
Sidney Poitier said I saw you once and I
looked in your eyes and there was a
connection and he says I give to you
responsibility so I'm taking that
responsibility tonight and Thank You
Sidney this is the this is probably
gonna be the toughest part of this
speech
my daughter shares my grandmother's name
Marie my grandmother's name is Estelle
Marie Talley and she's not here tonight
and this is gonna be the toughest part
but she was my first acting teacher she
told me stand up straight put your
shoulders back act like you got some
sense
we would go places and I would wile out
and she says act like you've been
somewhere uh and then when I would act a
fool she would she would beat me she
would whip me and she could get an Oscar
for the way she whupped me because she
was great at it
and after she whipped me she would talk
to me and tell me why she whipped me
said I want you to be a Southern
gentleman and she still talks to me now
only now she talks to me in my dreams
and I can't wait to go to sleep tonight
because we got a lot to talk about I
love you